[Music]
braden is with us in tulsa hi brayden
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you doing good man
what's up
good um i
just have a concern i feel
kind of like my my wife and i are
drowning
um
we
have a two-year-old and we're expecting
another
baby in october you are drowning
congrats brayden it's awesome man thank
you that's great but wow what a house
full of what a house full of this is a
lot going on here
definitely
um on to the drowning part
um my wife and i she's a teacher i just
work part-time because i'm trying to go
to school full-time
and we make about
fifty thousand dollars a year and
um
that turns out to be about
thirty six hundred dollars a month
and
we have a thousand dollar mortgage
payment we
looked at 400 for groceries and our
total debt payments are about a thousand
um
we have
ten thousand on credit card debt
um 24 000 in student loans that are
paying on that now 10 000 on card loans
and
all of that
just
leaves us with very minimal oh yeah
you've got no room in this budget
yeah so uh when do you graduate
i graduate in
let's see fall 2023
so in a year and a half basically and
what
in human resources management
okay
um you got a tough 18 months ahead of
you
uh you got a lot going on babies young
marriage debt coming out your ears your
house payments too big
your other debts are too big yeah you
are overwhelmed i don't blame you i get
it i see how you feel drowning um but
you're gonna you're gonna work
an extra job a lot more than you are now
you've got to get your income up or
something's gonna have to give
and the something may be selling the
house it may be selling the car it may
be selling both of them but the numbers
you're giving me are not sustainable
that's why you feel like you're drowning
yeah we have ten thousand for two cars
so my wife and i both have a car yeah
okay you've not got not got super
expensive cars but but a thousand dollar
house payment on a 30 600 take home pay
is not sustainable
now you can you can you can do that for
18 months but you're to have to be door
dashing and delivering pizzas and some
other stuff you are going to have a a
bizarre schedule you all are going to be
exhausted within this 18 months but at
least then you'll be able to go get a
job making 50 or 60 000 bucks
if you can hang on
do something ridiculous to hang on for
the 18 months and get out the other side
you can make it but
you're not even going to make it 18
months with what you got right in front
of you something's going to give
hang on we're going to put you through
financial peace university is our gift